[Applause]
ah thank you very much
thank you very much thank you
thank you very much
friends delegates and distinguished
guests please
i stand before you tonight honored by
your support
proud of the extraordinary progress we
have made together over the last
four incredible years and brimming with
confidence
in the bright future we will build for
america
over the next four years
we begin this evening our thoughts
are with the wonderful people who have
just come through the wrath
of hurricane laura we are working
closely
with state and local officials in texas
louisiana
arkansas mississippi sparing no effort
to save lives
while the hurricane was fierce one of
the strongest to make landfall
in 150 years the casualties and damage
were far less than thought possible only
24 hours ago
and this is due to the great work of
fema
law enforcement and the individual
states
i will be going this weekend
and congratulations thank you for that
great job out there we really appreciate
it
we are one national family and we will
always
protect love and care for each other
here tonight are the people who have
made my journey possible
and filled my life with so much joy
for her incredible service to our nation
and its children
i want to thank our magnificent first
lady
thank you
i also want to thank my amazing daughter
ivanka for that introduction and to
all of my children ivanka please stand
up
thank you
and to all of my children and
grandchildren i love you more than words
can express
i know my brother robert is looking down
on us
right now from heaven
he was a great brother and was very
proud
of the job we are all doing
thank you we love you robert
let us also take a moment to show our
profound appreciation
for a man who has always fought by our
side
and stood up for our values a man of
deep faith
and steadfast conviction our
vice president mike pence
and mike is joined by his beloved wife a
teacher
and military mom karen pence thank you
karen
my fellow americans tonight with a heart
full of gratitude and boundless optimism
i profoundly accept this nomination
for president of the united states
the republican party the party of
abraham lincoln goes forward united
determined and ready to welcome millions
of democrats
independents and anyone who believes in
the greatness of
america and the righteous heart
of the american people
in a new term as president we will again
build the greatest economy in history
quickly returning to full employment
soaring incomes and record prosperity
we will defend america against all
threats
and protect america against all dangers
we will lead america into new frontiers
of ambition
and discovery and we will reach
for new heights of national achievement
we will rekindle new faith in our values
new pride in our history and a new
spirit of unity that can only be
realized through love
for our great country
because we understand that america is
not a land cloaked in darkness
america is the torch that enlightens the
entire world
gathered here at our beautiful and
majestic
white house known all over the world as
the people's house
we cannot help but marvel at the miracle
that is our great american story
this has been the home of larger than
life figures like teddy roosevelt
and andrew jackson who rallied americans
to bold visions of a bigger
and brighter future within these walls
lived
tenacious generals like president grant
and eisenhower who led our soldiers
in the cause of freedom from these
grounds
thomas jefferson sent lewis and clark
on a daring expedition to cross a wild
and uncharted continent in the depths
of a bloody civil war president
abraham lincoln looked out
these very windows upon a half-completed
washington monument and asked god
in his providence to save our nation
two weeks after pearl harbor franklin
delano roosevelt
welcomed winston churchill
and just inside they set our people on a
course to victory
in the second world war
in recent months our nation and the
entire planet
has been struck by a new and powerful
invisible enemy like those brave
americans before us
we are meeting this challenge we are
delivering life-saving therapies
and will produce a vaccine before the
end of the year
or maybe even sooner
we will defeat the virus end the
pandemic
and emerge stronger than ever before
what united generations passed was an
unshakable confidence
in america's destiny and an unbreakable
faith
in the american people they knew that
our country is blessed by god
and has a special purpose in this world
it is that conviction that inspired the
formation of our union
our westward expansion
the abolition of slavery the passage of
civil rights
the space program and the overthrow of
fascism
tyranny and communism this towering
american spirit has prevailed over every
challenge
and lifted us to the summit of human
endeavor and yet despite all of our
greatness as a nation everything
we have achieved is now in danger
this is the most important election in
the history of our country
[Applause]
thank you at no time before
have voters faced a clearer choice
between two parties
two visions two philosophies
or two agendas this election will decide
whether we save the american dream
or whether we allow a socialist agenda
to demolish
our cherished destiny
it will decide whether we rapidly create
millions of high-paying jobs
or whether we crush our industries and
send millions of these jobs overseas
as has foolishly been done for many
decades
your vote will decide whether we protect
law-abiding americans
or whether we give free rein to
violent anarchists and agitators and
criminals
who threaten our citizens
and this election will decide whether we
will defend the american way of life or
whether we will allow a
radical movement to completely dismantle
and destroy it that won't happen
at the democrat national convention joe
biden and his party repeatedly assailed
america as a land of racial economic and
social injustice
so tonight i ask you a simple question
how can the democrat party ask to lead
our country
when it spends so much time tearing down
our country
in the left's backward view they do not
see america as the most free
just and exceptional nation on earth
instead they see a wicked nation that
must be punished
for its sins our opponents say that
redemption for you can only come
from giving power to them this is a
tired anthem spoken by every repressive
movement
throughout history but in this country
we don't look to
career politicians for salvation in
america we don't turn to government
to restore our souls we put our faith in
almighty god
[Music]
joe biden is not a savior of america's
soul he is the destroyer of america's
jobs
and if given the chance he will be the
destroyer
of american greatness for 47 years joe
biden
took the donations of blue-collar
workers
gave them hugs and even kisses
and told them he felt their pain
and then he flew back to washington and
voted to ship our jobs to china
and many other distant lands
joe biden spent his entire career
outsourcing
their dreams and the dreams of
american workers offshoring
their jobs opening their borders and
sending their sons and daughters to
fight
in endless foreign wars
wars that never ended
four years ago i ran for president
because i could not watch this betrayal
of our country any longer i could not
sit by
as career politicians let other
countries take advantage of us
on trade borders foreign policy and
national defense
our nato partners as an example
were very far behind in their defense
payments
but at my strong urging
they agreed to pay 130 billion dollars
more a year the first time in over 20
years that they
upped their payments
and this 130 billion dollars
will ultimately go to 400 billion
dollars a year and secretary
general stoltenberg who heads nato
was amazed after watching for so many
years and said that president trump
did what no one else was able to do
thank you
from the moment i left my former life
behind
and it was a good life
i have done nothing but fight for you
i did what our political establishment
never expected
and could never forgive breaking the
cardinal rule of washington politics
i kept my promise
together we have ended the rule of the
failed political class
and they are desperate to get their
power back
by any means necessary you've seen that
they are angry at me because instead of
putting them first i very simply
said america first
thank you days after taking office we
shocked the washington establishment and
withdrew from the
last administration's job-killing
trans-pacific
partnership
i then immediately approved the keystone
xl
and dakota access pipelines
ended the unfair and very costly paris
climate accord
and secured for the first time american
energy independence
we passed record-setting tax and
regulation cuts
at a rate nobody had ever seen before
within three short years we built the
strongest economy
in the history of the world washington
insiders asked me not to
stand up to china they pleaded with me
to let china continue stealing our jobs
ripping us off
and robbing our country blind
but i kept my word to the american
people
we took the toughest boldest strongest
and hardest hitting action against china
in american history
by far
they said that it would be impossible to
terminate and replace
nafta but again they were wrong
earlier this year i ended the nafta
nightmare
and signed the brand new u.s mexico
canada agreement
into law
and right now auto companies and others
are building their plants and factories
in america
not firing their employees and not
deserting us
for other countries
in perhaps no area did the washington
special interest try harder to stop
us than on my policy of pro-american
immigration
but i refuse to back down and today
america's borders
are more secure than ever
before
thank you we ended catch and release
stopped asylum fraud took down human
traffickers
who prey on women and children and we
have deported
twenty thousand gang members and five
hundred thousand
criminal aliens
[Applause]
we have already built 300 miles of
border wall
and we are adding 10 new miles every
single week
the war will soon be complete and it is
working beyond our wildest
[Applause]
expectations we are joined this evening
by members of the border patrol union
representing our country's courageous
border agents
thank you very much for being here thank
you brave
brave people
[Applause]
you see this country loves our law
enforcement they do thank you
they really do love and respect
when i learned that the tennessee valley
authority laid off hundreds of american
workers
and forced them to train their lower
paid foreign replacement
i promptly removed the chairman of the
board
and now those talented american workers
have been
rehired and are back providing power to
georgia
alabama tennessee kentucky mississippi
north carolina and virginia
they have their old jobs back and some
are here with us this evening please
stand you went through a lot
please stand thank you thank you very
much
you've been through a lot
thank you very much
last month i took on big pharma
you think that's easy and signed orders
that will massively lower the cost of
your prescription drugs
and give critically ill patients access
to life-saving cures
we passed the decades long awaited
right to try right to try
we also passed va accountability and va
choice our great veterans for taking
care of our veterans
91 approval rating this month the va
given by our veterans first time
anything like that's ever happened
by the end of my first term we will have
approved more than
300 federal judges including two great
new
supreme court justices
and to bring prosperity to our forgotten
inner cities
we worked hard to pass historic criminal
justice reform
prison reform opportunity zones
and long-term funding of historically
black colleges and universities
and before the china virus came in
produced the best
unemployment numbers for americans
hispanic americans and
asian americans ever recorded
and i say very modestly that i have done
more for the african-american community
than any president since
abraham lincoln our first republican
president
and i have done more in three years for
the black community
than joe biden has done in 47 years
and when i'm reelected the best is yet
to come
oh
thank you very much
[Applause]
when i took office the middle east was
in total chaos
isis was rampaging iran was on the rise
and the war in afghanistan had no end in
sight
i withdrew from the terrible one-sided
iran nuclear deal
unlike many presidents before me i kept
my promise recognized israel's true
capital
and moved our embassy to jerusalem
but not only did we talk about it as a
future site
we got it built rather than spending
one billion dollars on a new building as
planned
took an already owned existing building
in a better location
real estate deal right
and opened it at a cost of less than
five hundred thousand dollars
many things like that that government is
doing right now
we also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
and this month we achieved the first
middle east peace deal in 25
years thank you to uae
thank you to israel
in addition we obliterated 100
of the isis caliphate and killed its
founder
and leader abu bakar
al-baghdadi
then in a separate operation we
eliminated the world's
number one terrorist by far kasim
solomini
unlike previous administrations i have
kept america
out of new wars and our troops are
coming home
we have spent nearly 2.5 trillion
dollars on
completely rebuilding our military which
was very badly depleted
when i took office as you know this
includes
three separate pay raises for our
great warriors
we also launched the space force
the first new branch of the united
states military since the air force was
created almost 75
years ago we have spent the last four
years
reversing the damage joe biden inflicted
over the last 47 years
biden's record is a shameful roll call
of the most catastrophic betrayals and
blunders
in our lifetime he has spent his entire
career on the wrong side of history
biden voted for the nafta disaster the
single worst trade deal
ever enacted he supported china's entry
into the world trade organization one of
the greatest economic
disasters of all time
after those biden calamities the united
states lost
one in four manufacturing jobs we laid
off workers in michigan
ohio new hampshire pennsylvania
and many other states they didn't want
to hear
biden's hollow words of empathy
they wanted their jobs back
as vice president he supported the
trans-pacific partnership
which would have been a death sentence
for
the u.s auto industry he backed
the horrendous south korea trade deal
which took many jobs from our country
and which i've reversed and made a great
deal for our country
he repeatedly supported mass amnesty
for illegal immigrants he voted for the
iraq war
he opposed the mission to take out osama
bin laden
he opposed killing solomani he oversaw
the rise of isis
and cheered the rise of china as a
positive development for america and the
world some positive development
that's why china supports joe biden and
desperately wants him to win i can tell
you that
upon very good information
china would own our country if joe biden
got elected
unlike biden i will hold them fully
accountable
for the tragedy that they caused all
over the world they caused
in recent months our nation and the
world has been hit by the
once in a century pandemic that china
allowed to spread around the globe
they could have stopped it but they
allowed it to come out
we are grateful to be joined tonight by
several of our incredible
nurses and first responders please stand
and accept our profound
thanks and gratitude
many americans including me
have sadly lost friends and cherished
loved ones
to this horrible disease as one nation
we mourn we grieve and we hold in our
hearts forever the memories of all of
those lives
that have been so tragically taken so
unnecessary
in their honor we will unite in their
memory
we will overcome and when the china
virus hit
we launched the largest national
mobilization since world war
ii invoking the defense production act
we produced the world's largest supply
of ventilators
not a single american who has needed a
ventilator has been denied a ventilator
which is a miracle
good job heading the task force
by our great vice president thank you
very much mike please
please stand back
we shipped hundreds of millions of
masked gloves and gowns to our front
line healthcare workers
to protect our nation's seniors we rush
supplies
testing kits and personal to
nursing homes we gave everything you can
possibly give and we're still giving it
because we're taking care
of our senior citizens
army corps of engineers built field
hospitals
and the navy deployed our great hospital
ships
we developed from scratch the largest
and most advanced
testing system anywhere in the world
america has tested more than every
country in europe
put together and more than every nation
in the western hemisphere combined think
of that
we have conducted 40 million more tests
than the next
closest nation which is india
we developed a wide array of effective
treatments including a powerful antibody
treatment
known as convalescent plasma you saw
that on sunday night when we announced
it
that will save thousands and thousands
of lives
thanks to advances we have pioneered the
fatality rate and you look at it and you
look at the numbers
it has been reduced by 80 percent
since april 80 percent
the united states has among the lowest
case fatality rates
of any major country anywhere in the
world
the european union's case fatality rate
is nearly three times higher than ours
but you don't hear that
they don't write about that they don't
want to write about that they don't want
you to know those things
all together the nations of europe have
experienced a 30 percent greater
increase in excess mortality
than the united states think of that we
enacted the largest package of financial
relief
in american history thanks to our
paycheck protection program
we have saved or supported more than
50 million american jobs that's one of
the reasons that we're
advancing so rapidly with our economy
great as job result we have seen the
smallest
economic contraction of any major
western nation
and we are recovering at a much faster
rate than anybody
over the past three months we have
gained over nine
million jobs and that's a record in the
history of our country
unfortunately from the beginning our
opponents have shown themselves capable
of nothing but a partisan
ability to criticize when i took
bold action to issue a travel ban on
china
very early indeed joe biden called it
hysterical and xenophobic and then i
introduced a ban on europe very early
again
if we had listened to joe hundreds of
thousands more americans would have died
instead of following the science joe
biden wants to inflict a painful
shutdown
on the entire country his shutdown would
inflict
unthinkable and lasting harm on our
nation's children
families and citizens of all backgrounds
the cost of the biden shutdown
would be measured in increased drug
overdoses depression
alcohol addiction suicides heart attacks
economic devastation job loss
and much more joe biden's plan
is not a solution to the virus but
rather it's a surrender to the virus
my administration has a very different
approach
to save as many lives as possible we are
focusing on the science the facts and
the data
we are aggressively sheltering those at
highest risk especially the elderly wire
allowing lower risk americans to safely
return
to work and to school and we want to see
so many of those great
states be opened by democrats
we want them to be open they have to be
open they have to get back to work
[Applause]
they have to get back to work and they
have to get back to school
most importantly we are marshaling
america's scientific genius
to produce a vaccine in record time
under operation warp speed we have three
different vaccines in the final stage of
trials
right now years ahead of what has
been achieved before nobody thought it
could ever be done this fast normally it
would be years that we did it in a
matter of a few months
we are producing them in advance so that
hundreds of millions of doses will be
quickly available we will have a safe
and effective vaccine this year
and together we will crush the virus
at the democrat convention you barely
heard a word about
their agenda but that's not because they
don't have one
it's because their agenda is the most
extreme set of proposals ever put
forward by a
major party nominee joe biden may claim
he is an ally of the light but when it
comes to his agenda biden wants to keep
us
completely in the dark he doesn't have a
clue
he has pledged a four trillion dollar
tax hike
on almost all american families which
will totally collapse our rapidly
improving
economy and once again
record stock markets that we have right
now
will also collapse that means your 401ks
that means all of the stocks that you
have
on the other hand just as i did in my
first term
i will cut taxes even further for
hard-working moms and dads
i will not raise taxes i will cut them
and very substantially
and we will also provide tax credits to
bring jobs out of china
back to america and we will impose
tariffs on any company
that leaves america to produce jobs
overseas
we will make sure our companies and jobs
stay in our country
as i've already been doing for quite
some time if you've noticed
joe biden's agenda is
made in china my agenda is
made in the usa
[Applause]
biden has promised to abolish the
production of american oil
coal shale and natural gas laying waste
to the
economies of pennsylvania ohio
texas north dakota oklahoma
colorado and new mexico destroying those
states
absolutely destroying those states and
others
millions of jobs will be lost and energy
prices will soar
these same policies led to crippling
power
outages in california just last week
everybody saw that tremendous power
outage nobody's seen anything like it
but we saw that last week in california
how can joe biden claim to be an ally of
the light
when his own party can't even keep the
lights on
joe biden's campaign has even published
a 110-page policy platform you can't get
away from this
co-authored with far left senator
crazy bernie sanders the biden-bernie
manifesto calls for
suspending all removals of illegal
aliens implementing
nationwide catch and release and
providing illegal aliens with free
taxpayer-funded lawyers everybody gets a
lawyer come on over to our country
everybody has a lawyer we have a lawyer
for you that's what we need is more
lawyers
joe biden recently raised his hand
on the debate stage and promised to your
giveaway he was going to give it away
your health care dollars to illegal
immigrants which is going to bring
massive numbers of
immigrants into our country massive
numbers will pour into our country in
order to get
all of the goodies that they want to
give education health care
everything he also supports deadly
sanctuary cities that protect criminal
aliens he promised to end national
security travel bans from jihadist
nations
and he pledged to increase refugee
admissions by
700 percent
this is in the manifesto
the biden plan would eliminate america's
borders
in the middle of a global pandemic
and he's even talking about taking the
wall down how about that
[Music]
biden also vowed to oppose school choice
and clothes
all charter schools ripping away the
ladder of opportunity for black and
hispanic children
in a second term i will expand charter
schools and provide school choice to
every family in america
and we will always treat our teachers
with the tremendous
respect that they deserve
great people great great people
joe biden claims he has empathy
for the vulnerable yet the party he
leads supports the extreme
late term abortion of defenseless babies
right up until the moment of birth
democrat leaders talk about moral
decency
but they have no problem with stopping a
baby's
beating heart in the ninth month of
pregnancy
democrat politicians refuse to protect
innocent life
and then they lecture us about morality
and saving
america's soul tonight we proudly
declare
that all children born and unborn
have a god-given right to life
during the democrat convention the words
under god
were removed from the pledge of
allegiance
not once but twice we will never do that
but the fact is this is where they're
coming from
like it or not this is where they're
coming from
if the left gains power they will
demolish the suburbs
confiscate your guns and appoint
justices who will wipe away your second
amendment and other constitutional
freedoms
biden is a trojan horse for socialism if
joe biden doesn't have the strength
to stand up to wild-eyed
marxists like bernie sanders and his
fellow radicals and there are many
there are many many we see him all the
time it's incredible actually
then how is he ever going to stand up
for you
he's not the most dangerous aspect of
the biden platform
is the attack on public safety
the biden bernie manifesto calls for
abolishing cash bail
immediately releasing 400 000 criminals
onto the streets and
into your neighborhoods when asked if he
supports cutting police funding
joe biden replied yes absolutely
when congresswoman ilhan omar
called the minneapolis police department
a cancer that is rotten to the root
biden wouldn't disavow her support and
reject her endorsement he proudly
displayed it
shortly later on his website
displayed it in big letters make no
mistake
if you give power to joe biden the
radical left will defund
police departments all across america
they will pass federal legislation to
reduce law enforcement nationwide
they will make every city look like
democrat-run portland
oregon no one will be safe in biden's
america
my administration will always stand with
the men
and women of law enforcement
every day police officers risk their
lives to keep
us safe and every year many sacrifice
their lives
in the line of duty one of these
incredible americans was detective
miostas familia she was part of a team
of american heroes
called the nypd or new york's finest who
i was very very proud
to get their endorsement just the other
day
great people great great people
they were allowed to do their job you'd
have no crime in new york
rudy giuliani knows that better than
anybody
thank you three years ago in the fourth
of july weekend
detective familia was on duty in her
vehicle when she was ambushed just after
midnight
and murdered by a monster who hated her
purely
for wearing the badge detective familia
was a single mom
she recently asked for the night shift
so she could spend more time with her
kids two years ago i stood in front of
the u.s capitol alongside those
beautiful children
and held their grandmother's hand as
they mourned their terrible loss
and we honored detective familia's
extraordinary life it was extraordinary
detective familia's three children
are with us this evening genesis peter
delilah
we are so grateful to have you here
tonight
thank you very much for coming thank you
very much
thank you very much
i promise you that we will treasure your
mom in our memories forever
we must remember that the overwhelming
majority of police officers in this
country
and that's the overwhelming majority
are noble courageous and honorable
we have to give law enforcement our
police
back their power
they are afraid to act
they are afraid to lose their pension
they are afraid to lose their jobs
and by being afraid they are not able to
do
the job that they so desperately want to
do for you
and those who suffer most are the great
people
who they protect and who they want to
protect
at an even higher level when there is
police misconduct the justice system
must hold wrongdoers fully and
completely accountable
and it will but when we can never
have a situation where things
are going on as they are today
we must never allow mob rule
we can never allow marlboro
in the strongest possible terms the
republican party condemns the rioting
looting arson and violence we have seen
in democrat-run cities all
like kenosha minneapolis portland
chicago and new york and many others
democrat run
there is violence and danger in the
streets of many democrat-run cities
throughout america
this problem could easily be fixed
if they wanted to just call we're ready
to go in
we'll take care of your problem in a
matter of hours just call
we have to wait for the call it's too
bad we have to but we have to wait for
the call
we must always have law and order
all federal crimes are being
investigated prosecuted and punished to
the fullest extent of the law
when the anarchists started ripping down
our statues and monuments
right outside i signed an order
immediately
ten years in prison and it was a miracle
it all stopped no more statues
they said that's just too long as they
looked at a statue i think we'll rip it
down then they said 10 years in prison i
think that's too long
let's go home during their
convention joe biden and his supporters
remain
completely silent about the rioters and
criminals
spreading mayhem in democrat-run cities
they never even mentioned it during
their entire
convention never once mentioned now
they're starting to mention it
because their poll numbers are going
down like a rocking water
it's too late joe in the face of
left-wing
anarchy and mayhem in minneapolis
chicago and other cities
joe biden's campaign did not condemn it
they donated to it at least 13 members
of joe biden's campaign
staff donated to a fund to bail out
vandals arsonists
anarchists looters and rioters from jail
here tonight is the grieving family of
retired police captain
david dorn a 38-year veteran
of the saint louis police department a
great man and a highly respected man by
all
in june captain dorne was shot and
killed as he tried to protect the store
from
rioters and looters or as the democrats
would call them peaceful protesters
they call them peaceful protesters
we're honored to be joined tonight
by his wonderful wife ann and beloved
family members brian and kalyn
to each of you we will never forget the
heroic
legacy of captain david dorn thank you
very much for being here thank you
thank you very much great man great man
as long as i am president we will defend
the absolute right of every american
citizen to live in security dignity and
peace
if the democrat party wants to stand
with anarchists
agitators rioters looters and flag
burners
that is up to them but i as your
president
will not be a part of it the republican
party will remain the voice of the
patriotic heroes
who keep america safe and salute
the american flag
last year over 1 000 african americans
were murdered as a result of violent
crime in just
four democrat-run cities
top 10 most dangerous cities in the
country
are run by democrats and have been for
many decades
thousands more african-americans are
victim
and victims of violent crime
in these communities joe biden and the
left
ignore these american victims
i never will if the radical left takes
power
they will apply their disastrous
policies to every city town and suburb
in america just imagine if the so-called
peaceful demonstrators in the streets
were in charge of
every lever of power in the u.s
government
just think of that liberal politicians
claim to be concerned about the strength
of american institutions but who exactly
is attacking them who is hiring the
radical professors
judges and prosecutors who is trying to
abolish immigration enforcement
and establish speech codes designed to
muzzle
dissent in every case the attacks on
american institutions are being waged by
radical
left always remember
they are coming after me because i am
fighting for you that's what's happening
and it's been going on from before i
even got elected
and remember this they spied on my
campaign and they got caught
let's see now what happens
we must reclaim our independence from
the left's
repressive mandates americans are
exhausted
trying to keep up with the latest lists
of approved words and phrases
and the ever more restrictive political
decrees
many things have a different name now
and the rules are constantly changing
the goal of cancel culture is to make
decent americans live in fear of being
fired
expelled shamed humiliated and driven
from society as we know it
the far left wants to coerce you into
saying
what you know to be false and scare you
out of saying
what you know to be true very sad
but on november 3rd you can send them a
very thundering message
they will never forget
thank you
thank you very much
joe biden is weak
he takes his marching orders from
liberal
hypocrites who drive their cities into
the ground while fleeing far from the
scene
of the wreckage these same liberals want
to eliminate school choice
while they enroll their children in the
finest private schools in the land
they want to open our borders while
living in waldorf compounds and
communities
in the best neighborhoods in the world
they want to defund the police while
they have armed guards for themselves
this november we must turn the page
forever on this failed
political class the fact is i'm here
[Applause]
what's the name of that building
but i'll say it differently the fact is
we're here
and they're not
to me one of the most beautiful
buildings anywhere in the world and it's
not a building it's a home as far as i'm
concerned
not even a house it's a home it's a
wonderful place
with an incredible history but it's all
because of you
together we will write the next chapter
of the great american story
over the next four years we will make
america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world
we will expand opportunity zones thank
you
tim scott bring home
our medical supply chains and we will
end our resilience
for bad things we will go right after
china
we will not rely on them one bit we're
taking our business
out of china we are bringing it home
we want our business to come home
we will continue to reduce taxes and
regulations at levels
not seen before we will create 10
million
jobs in the next 10 months and it'll be
higher than that
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and surge federal prosecutors into
high crime communities we will ban
deadly sanctuary cities and ensure that
federal health care is protected
for american citizens not for illegal
aliens
we will have strong borders and i've
said for years without borders we don't
have a country
don't have a country strike down
terrorists who threaten our people
and keep america out of endless and
costly foreign wars
we will appoint prosecutors judges
justices
who believe in enforcing the law
not enforcing their own political
agenda
which is illegal we will ensure equal
justice for citizens of
every race religion color and creed
we will uphold your religious liberty
and defend
your second amendment right to keep and
bear arms
uh
and if we don't win your second
amendment doesn't have a chance
i can tell you that i have totally
protected it
we will protect medicare and social
security
we will always and very strongly protect
patients with pre-existing conditions
and that is a pledge from the entire
republican party thank you kevin
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency and further reduce
the cost of prescription drugs and
health insurance premiums that coming
way down
we will greatly expand energy
development
continuing to remain the number one
in the world and keep america
energy independent
and for those of you that still drive a
car
look how low your gasoline bill is you
haven't seen that in a long time
we will win the race to 5g and build the
world's best
cyber and missile defense already under
construction we will fully restore
patriotic education to our schools and
always protect
we will always always protect free
speech
on college campuses
and we put a very big penalty in
they do anything having to do with your
free speech
colleges have to pay a tremendous
tremendous financial penalty and again
it's amazing
how open they've been lately we will
launch
a new age of american ambition in space
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation to plant
its beautiful flag on mars
this is the unifying national agenda
that will bring our country together
so tonight i say to all americans this
is the most
important election in the history of our
country
there has never been such a difference
between two parties or two
individuals in ideology philosophy
or vision than there is right now
our opponents believe that america is a
depraved nation
we want our sons and daughters to know
the truth
america is the greatest and most
exceptional nation
in the history of the world
our country wasn't built by cancer
culture
speech codes and soul-crushing
conformity
we are not a nation of timid spirits
we are a nation of fierce proud and
independent
american patriots we're a nation of
pilgrims pioneers adventurers
explorers and trailblazers who refuse to
be tied down
held back or in any way reigned in
americans have still in their spines
grit in their souls and fire in their
hearts
there is no one like us on earth
i want every child in america to know
that you are part of the most exciting
and incredible
adventure in human history
matter where your family comes from no
matter your background in america
anyone can rise with hard work
devotion and drive you can reach any
goal
and achieve every ambition
our american ancestors sailed across
the perilous ocean to build a new life
on a new continent they braved the
freezing winters
crossed the raging rivers scaled the
rocky peaks
trekked the dangerous forests
and worked from dawn till dusk
these pioneers didn't have money they
didn't have fame
but they had each other they love their
families
they love their country and they love
their god
when opportunity beckoned
they picked up their bibles packed up
their belongings
climbed into their covered wagons
and set out west for the next adventure
ranchers and miners cowboys and sheriffs
farmers and settlers they pressed on
past the mississippi
to stake a claim in the wild frontier
legends were born why erp
annie oakley davy crockett
and buffalo bill americans built their
beautiful homesteads
on the open range soon they had churches
and communities
then towns and with time great centers
of industry and commerce
that is who they were
americans build their future we don't
tear down
our past we are the nation
that won a revolution
toppled tyranny and fascism
and delivered millions into freedom
we laid down the railroads built the
great ships
raised up the skyscrapers revolutionized
industry
and sparked a new age of scientific
discovery
we set the trends in art and music radio
and film
sport and literature and we did it all
with style and confidence and flair
because that is who we are
whenever our way of life was threatened
our heroes
answered the call from yorktown to
gettysburg
from normandy to iwo jima
american patriots raced into canon
blasts
bullets and bayonets to rescue american
liberty they had no fear
but america didn't stop there
we looked into the sky and kept pressing
onward
we built a 6 million pound rocket and
launched it thousands of miles into
space
we did it so that two brave patriots
could stand tall and salute
our wondrous american flag planted on
the face of the moon
for america nothing is impossible
over the next four years we will prove
worthy of this
magnificent legacy we will reach
stunning new heights and we will show
that the world
for america there is a dream
and it is not beyond your reach
together we are unstoppable together we
are unbeatable
because together we are the proud
citizens
of the united states of america
and on november 3rd
we will make america
safer we will make america stronger
we will make america prouder
and we will make america greater than
ever before
i am very very proud to be
the nominee of the republican party
i love you all god bless you and god
bless america thank you very much
you